a long time ago when I was 10 years old
I discovered the first album of this
comic book Elena and I was like oh my
god what is this thing I think what
strike me is the storytelling it was the
first time that we see the modern couple
they were acting like two normal people
today he said that they are in the
twenty eighth century and everything is
weird the environment was just crazy
it's like aliens everywhere and world's
everywhere when I was working on the
Fifth Element with Miss year main
designer from valerian he was the one
saying why don't do Vinay and why do you
do this Fifth Element thing I mean the
technology was not good at the time it
was not possible and that way later
avatar arrived on avatar makes
everything possible there is no limit
anymore man I do there sorry where
should use now 14 years ago did you ever
think you would get turned into a movie
no we start to work with the artist
three years before start the phone start
the storyboard a year and a half before
we were so prepped when we start the
film that the shooting almost looks easy
one two three we have an area and Laura
lein there are two cops show your gun
when you aim
good job boy and they can travel in
space and time
valerian is little pretentious India
reckon I could get reply how about you
month for backup
right change he always think he will
save the day everything is a little too
easy friend Laura lein is probably my
first love 10 years old you know you
start to get feeling okay Hansen things
a lot better
nice to see you we're not allowed to
splendid as ever
you're very human big fight and he's
desperately in love with her
[Music]
[Applause]
I just gave topic with a lot water their
mission bring them to Space Station met
above a thousand alien species from the
four corners of the universe
welcome to alpha alpha called the city
of thousand planets because all the
knowledge in the universe is there the
Alpha station has 3236 species with over
5,000 languages spoken it's Wall Street
TG of science United Nations brought
away everything in there so it makes the
city the most important in the entire
university it's paradise
it has always been my dreams to put
their character is on a big screen
and now it's the time
on the fifth element there is 188 the
fall effect shots when in valerian there
is 2734 I waited my entire life to make
this film and the journey has been
amazing I gave it everything I have and
I cannot wait to share it with you
so have fun see you inside
you
[Music]
you